[Applause]
all right before we go I want to share
one last happy story this is what I'm
[Music]
liking okay so y'all can walk down any
Manhattan Street and you're sure to find
vendors Hawking hot dogs tacos halal
food like all those NYC Staples then
there's this truck that bright pink
vision is the candy Zoo truck opened up
by three New York mamas last year and it
may be even more popular with grown-ups
than with kids I would love it uh we
have the owners on the line now watching
on NBC4 New York say hi to Tina Jen and
Karen
everybody what's up ladies so I have to
ask like how did this get started and i'
love everything behind you thank you so
much well Jenna is my oldest friend our
grandparents were friends our parents
were friends we were friends we always
wanted to do something together we
weren't really quite sure what that
would be but coming out of the pandemic
we knew it had to be something happy so
here we are candy we figured candy was a
way to go and our tuome became a
threesome we brought in Tina as a
partner and we bought a 1997 used truck
and we had it fabricated and here we are
this is our candy Zoo truck oh I love it
and I I love that y'all also work is it
true with Ronald McDonald house that's
right we partner with the Ronald
McDonald House to donate candy to all
the children with pediatric cancer and
their families because we want to bring
some happiness and joy into their life
and let them come up to the truck and
they get to choose their collections of
candy and it's the one thing that at
least they get to choose for themselves
since during the day they have all these
appointments that they can't you know
not go to and they have no control over
that so it's really nice to be able to
give back and see their smiling faces oh
you're bringing so much joy to people
thank you so much ladies for joining us
today this is awesome I'm liking your
post right now right thank you
absolutely and that is not all our
season one partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to rasal pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to celebrate
those fearlessly following their dreams
just like y'all so they're going to be
riding a check to the Ronald McDonald
House of New York on your behalf
[Music]
for thank you so much ladies and thank
you to all our guests this hour Eric
McCormack Jenna allance nazinga Prescott
Julia Amy and Grace Potter y'all have a
great day and if it's not well try and
change
[Applause]
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home